you
okay let's have a game against my
nemesis on chess calm the impossible one
it's been a while since I did a
recording while playing against this
machine who beats me up quite often many
of you on chess comm will know that fact
but let's see if we could somehow get a
close position out of this setup so
Kings Indian and I'm just going to be
focused on this dog and I'll maybe look
for Bishop h6 and the monster does not
take much time to think
does he all right let's continue Queen
d2 grabbing some space with b5 c5 have
to look into c5 and E 5 should I play
Bishop h6 or wait for Bishop g7 first I
think I wait for Bishop g7 first I get
my knight going if b4 I could reroute my
knight to f2 and I wanted to do this
move so that I can actually make this
move I want to make sure that this is
watched over just like in the if it if
this was an open Sicilian I want to
watch over that so Knight here that he's
ready to jump in there I'm gonna keep
him out this is a prep move for night
here Bishop takes pawn takes and then
there's pressure here and I can't really
support I really don't want to I don't
think that there's a better Square for
my knight so I want to stop each for now
I realized with b3 I have weakened this
diagonal c5 might come with that much
greater effect now Brooke d1 was my
thought but if after b4 then where does
my Knight go that is a little bit tricky
I really don't want to stay on this
diagonal
maybe I don't maybe I'm not tactically
vulnerable just yet I have enough
support for d4 so maybe now is where I
run with getting rid of the dark square
bishop if I Castle this could maybe
become an issue with Queen takes hmm he
could actually turn out to be out of
play
I'm actually not liking my night so much
anymore on g3 maybe I should have tried
to get an h4 hmm or h5 excuse me
all right we're gonna run with it though
we're going to run with it
mm-hmm let's castle the castle and then
okay here's the strike so I think I want
to try my best to keep things closed
yeah this Knight moves I have problems
here and there we go just like that this
monster I was wanting to meet the knight
move with Bishop g5 and just like that
I'm a pawn down oh man stuck maybe I
have that though probably still grab it
no that was a defense I had a knight
here with the fork I get to pick up the
dark square Bishop so he's still going
to fall and I'm gonna do something that
looks very ugly with my knight well what
can you do throw them in the corner
throw on the throw them in the corner
hope for the best I'm weakening my
position a great deal I'm losing control
and I'm down on time as usual oh I need
to get my knight doing something better
he's stupid in the corner so f2 is now
available and wait a second I'm actually
having some hope I have a little bit of
hope because the position is closing up
a little bit I'm okay with that I think
I want to get him here can I get that
I'd love to get that in there I'd love
to get that in there I want to go here
and close things up you're gonna push I
better stop that it's gonna be captured
no it's not so wait it's a little bit
closed
I'm having some hope can you hear him my
voice I have some hope against the
Machine my knight is stupid over here
I'm d1 okay let's go here my knight
wants to play he's playing 283 it's
never gonna happen
never I don't even make progress I guess
maybe get my knight here to g5 yeah I
knew that was coming
what can you do
all right so I have to prepare for the
doubling like this couldn't get in just
some trades why'd I do that then I was
stupid on h7 mine wasn't so brilliant on
h3 either so it's going back and forth
but I think with blacks space advantage
it wants to keep playing I can't go too
far I want to meet rook a - with rook
here you should just do this move right
now let's try that get my queen doing
something else 83 I would love to see 83
I would love that my knight needs to do
something else can I do this pawn push I
gotta go for something one-minute
warning
oh he's um what is he doing how do I
know his gender all of a sudden how did
I all of a sudden know his about his
gender I won't pressure on this pond no
then he would never take that or would
he would he always run for the hills I
feel like I have the computer on the
rope somehow let's chop that guy up my
queen over here 47 seconds oh here comes
that dangerous queen the ever so
dangerous Queen is here by light-square
bishop is a big dummy isn't he
it's doing nothing exciting oh yeah
alright let's come over here I guess
okay we're gonna have some trades okay -
I knew it I knew it
No ah oh no I shouldn't have done that
if the rooks gonna play here no he's not
Oh 30-second warning thirty seconds it's
just shuffling so draw you know it's a
drama oh come on I got to be able to do
something no that's too scary my knight
is a big dummy
oh my light square bishop is stupid I'll
have anything and I'll have anything 19
seconds oh my god that nights gonna kill
me
oh he's gonna kill me I gotta get these
rooks off I can't even do that though
I want to kill that [ __ ] up this is
game over and take one of them off this
is big trouble big trouble
alert my Knights dead my Knights dead
because their savable
not really Oh big trouble big trouble
three seconds it's never happening ah
that's gonna be ji Jeon Ji Won how do
you like that
ji Jeon Ji Won I had some hope with the
position closed up that's what I have to
go for those give me the best
opportunities to win ah man what can you
do though alright well it was exciting
at least I was getting a little bit
sight excited there I had some hope but
I go down again as usual against this
beast all right as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you